[Música]
la comunidad de igual día en texas eeuu
recordó a los 21 muertos del tiroteo
ocurrido el martes los asistentes
realizaron una vigilia en honor a las
víctimas la mayoría de ellas eran niños
entre 7 y 10 años el tiroteo reaviva el
debate por el control de armas en eeuu
los rusos siguen atacando al este
ucraniano y están cada vez más cerca de
severodonezk una de las dos únicas
ciudades que aún no han caído en la
provincia de lugansk por otra parte el
kremlin afirmó que reactivará el puerto
de mariupol la urbe ucraniana más grande
bajo su poder
se extiende el régimen de decepción en
el salvador por un mes más es la segunda
extensión que aprueba la asamblea
legislativa a petición del presidente
nayim bukele a pesar de que la medida
divide a la población y ha sido
criticada por organizaciones de derechos
humanos ampliaremos desde san salvador
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle empecemos
con la actualidad estadounidense el
miércoles hubo una vigilia para despedir
a los 19 menores de edad y a los dos
maestros que fueron asesinados en el
tiroteo en igual de texas este ha sido
el segundo más mortífero en una escuela
en eeuu el duelo se convirtió en una
confrontación mientras varios de los
asistentes se cuestionaban sobre el
control de armas por otra parte del
senado estudiados proyectos de ley para
regular la venta de armamento aunque los
intentos pueden fracasar
el tiroteo de texas ha reavivado una
disputa de larga data sobre el control
de armas en eeuu un estado abiertamente
proarmas reseñó así lo que ocurrió antes
del tiroteo el stand de información de
weston en el beas hasta este momento la
única información que se sabía de
antemano fue publicada por el pistolero
en facebook aproximadamente 30 minutos
antes de llegar a la escuela
de forestales walsh
la primera publicación fue el punto dijo
le voy a disparar a mi abuela la segunda
publicación fue le disparé a mi abuela
la tercera publicación tal vez menos de
15 minutos antes de llegar a la escuela
decía voy a disparar en una escuela
primaria wash and winding en el momento
tras su intervención el ex congresista
demócrata de terror que enfrentó al
gobernador acusándolo de no hacer nada
al respecto de la masacre los policías
respondieron fuertemente lo expulsaron
de la sala
tras el incidente aseguró a los
periodistas que se les debe una acción a
los padres y que es culpa de todos no
solo de los republicanos seguir
aceptando estas acciones el presidente
estadounidense joe biden anunció su
visita a la zona
viajaremos a texas en los próximos días
para reunirnos con las familias hacerles
saber que tenemos una idea sólo una idea
de su dolor y espero llevar un poco de
consuelo a la comunidad en estado de
shock dolor y trauma
baile también renovó sus críticas al
lobby de las armas en eeuu que lucha
contra los intentos de imponer
regulaciones más estrictas a esta
industria la poderosa asociación
nacional del rifle culpó de la masacre a
un criminal solitario y trastornado y se
espera que el viernes se realice la
convención anual que reunirá entre otros
al ex presidente de donald trump
en ucrania las tropas rusas alcanzaron
los suburbios de la ciudad de severo
donges una de las dos únicas urbes que
aún están en manos o craneanas la
provincia de lugansk aunque los ataques
y los bombardeos de rusia en esa región
han aumentado el avance militar es lento
y todavía no la controlan totalmente por
su lado moscú afirmó que el puerto de
mariupol volverá a funcionar con
normalidad después de que desactivaron
más de 12.000 artefactos explosivos que
estaban sembrados en la costa
recordemos que mariupol es la ciudad más
grande que ha capturado rusia hasta
ahora en ucrania en otros territorios
controlados por los rusos concretamente
en gerzón y sáb orilla el kremlin
anunció que le dará pasaportes rusos a
los habitantes
de las fuerzas armadas de ucrania
nuestra inteligencia y todos aquellos
que defienden el estado están
resistiendo la ofensiva extremadamente
feroz de las tropas rusas en el este de
jean goodall kinski son soldados en
algunas áreas el enemigo nos supera
significativamente en número con equipo
luz de estar coludido ahora hablemos de
las noticias latinoamericanas el régimen
de decepción en el salvador se extendió
por segunda vez a petición del
presidente nayib ukelele la asamblea
legislativa aprobó la prórroga con 67
votos a favor de los 84 posibles así
cuatro derechos de los salvadoreños
siguen interrumpidos desde finales de
marzo cuando entró en vigor la medida el
gobierno la propuso para frenar la ola
de violencia de las pandillas que se
cobró la vida de 87 personas un récord
histórico pero varias organizaciones han
denunciado violaciones de derechos
humanos desde sant salvador nuestro
corresponsal vladimir chamorro nos contó
más detalles de la extensión de
extensión por 30 días del estado de
excepción la solicitud del presidente
bucl
la constitución permite estar este tipo
de prórroga del estado de excepción
siempre y cuando se mantengan las
condiciones que llevaron a la primera
solicitud al respecto el ministro de
seguridad gustavo vía toro ha dicho que
las condiciones se mantienen y que
necesitan más tiempo para erradicar a
las pandillas en estos 60 días
aproximadamente 35.000 personas han sido
capturadas y como tú bien lo dices a la
par de esto en las organizaciones de
derechos humanos han registrado seis
centenares de denuncias de violaciones a
derechos humanos de capturas arbitrarias
de tratos inhumanos y degradantes dentro
de los centros penales que cabe decir
están sobre
esta curados por este alto número de
detenciones
tres organizaciones alertan que los
médicos cubanos que están en misiones
estatales en el exterior trabajan en
condiciones de esclavitud moderna la
denuncia de las ongs prisioneros
defenders chrd which to the americas y
la fundación internacional para la
libertad está basada en un informe que
se presentó en enero según su
información en 2020 hubo una misión de
médicos cubanos en méxico cada uno de
los 585 participantes recibió
724 dólares por tres meses de trabajo
cuando las autoridades mexicanas para
dar una cuba más de diez mil dólares por
cada uno de ellos profesionales
defenders agrega que las misiones de
internacionalización de cuba son una de
las mayores fuentes económicas del país
con hasta ocho mil quinientos millones
de dólares recaudados al año
los indígenas ecuatorianos fueron
galardonados con el premio goldman 2022
el máximo reconocimiento ambiental álex
licitante y alexandra narváez lideraron
un movimiento indígena en su comunidad
cofán para que la justicia cancelará 52
concesiones ilegales de extracción de
oro alva santana tiene los detalles de
este fallo histórico que protegió más de
30 mil hectáreas de la selva amazónica
la selva amazónica de ecuador fue el
destino del premio goldman este año
otorgado a dos indígenas de la etnia
cofán álex licitante y alexandra narváez
por su histórica victoria judicial que
permitió proteger sus territorios
sagrados de un mal común para los
indígenas la minería de oro
recibir el premio goldman simboliza la
esperanza espero seguir con esta lucha
para cuidar la amazonía y la vida este
premio es un símbolo de la fuerza
colectiva de los pueblos indígenas por
la defensa de nuestro territorio y de
nuestras vidas por el futuro de nuestros
niños este 2022 los ecuatorianos han
sido los únicos en latinoamericanos en
llevarse el considerado como el nobel
del medio ambiente un logro nada fácil
que comenzó en 2017 cuando narváez formó
una guardia indígena para monitorear y
frenar las actividades ilegales en su
territorio con lo que descubrieron
campamentos mineros improvisados al
enterarse el licitante sanador
tradicional y estudiante de derecho se
unió narváez y empezaron a la lucha
juntos
tras meses de batalla e investigaciones
con drones en 2018 consiguieron anular
52 concesiones ilegales de extracción de
oro protegiendo así 32 mil hectáreas de
selva tropical virgen y biodiversidad en
la comunidad de thin and go según los
ganadores
es un premio para todos los pueblos
indígenas de ecuador que llevan años
luchando contra la deforestación de su
territorio por las actividades
petroleras y mineras
y terminamos con una celebración
particular en perú este miércoles las
calles de lima fueron el escenario del
día del payaso decenas de personas
salieron a desfilar con grandes zapatos
pelucas coloridas y narices rojas los
claros peruanos celebran este día desde
1987 como homenaje al difunto josé
álvarez vélez conocido como tony perejil
y también como el payaso de los pobres
en solía visitar los barrios limeños en
la década del 80 para contagiar alegría
a los pobladores
hasta aquí las noticias ustedes sigan
conectados con france24
[Música]